hey how's it going I'm gonna try to do a
new series here called the day in the
life of a programmer or engineer
something like that and the whole point
is I know it's just gonna be like a
little vlog type thing
so as my career advances maybe some
other people need a little help
understanding what works and what
doesn't because I know I sure did and
I'm just hoping these will help I gotta
walk to my car hold on hold on okay well
well I sort of need some questions to go
off of to be honest but there's a few
things on my mind that I'm gonna talk
about as I just had some good news today
about things that happened and things
that have worked for me so far getting
to a degree certainly helped having a
github that has some actual stuff on it
that people like helped helped so I am I
saying helped
how do I say this well I just got
offered a new job and it's quite good
hold on I got to make a turn
okay and well I'm going to go pick up my
kid from school today but I thought I'd
talk to you guys a little while I'm
driving so I like talking about driving
it seems to work well for me for some
reason okay so I just landed a new job I
was very I really wanted the job it was
right up my alley
C++ involved a lot of linear algebra
stuff so I got an interview lined up
when did the interview and some other
people interviewed and they said damn
but you know after we do all the
interviews and they let me know I got it
so what did I do with this interview
that was like so special that made me
get picked over everybody else - it's a
nice job it's a cushy don't want to
speak about it too much like I don't
want to spoil anything but let's just
say it's about as good of a job as I
could possibly get for my livelihood
like I couldn't imagine anything with a
healthier environment it seems very very
good
so I I need this for my family of course
that's great and okay so let's get to it
why would they pick me over anybody else
why did they know I don't know all their
reasons but I can tell you how the
interview went and what I think I did
right what I think I did wrong and maybe
a little bit of what was the expectation
seemed like so let's start with the
basics what did I wear I had this beard
in this air I didn't do anything too
special other than make sure it wasn't
like a mangled mess and you know the
usual stuff of hygiene
so I didn't like overpaying for myself I
wore a dress shirt I had a coat on a
little jacket because it was a breezy
cold day on the entire time so I don't
even know if they saw my shirt but they
could see at the top that I was buttoned
up so they probably didn't even really
know what I was wearing and you know it
slacks and nice like she was actually
Geek Squad shoes that are like twelve
years old from when I worked at eek
squad but they weren't great as dress
shoes because they're all black and I
don't so I didn't like dress super nice
I didn't go in a tux or anything like
that like some people do I was just
myself I just showed up I look nice not
overdoing it and I was myself that's
what I do I wouldn't want to overdo it
one of the things I do when trying to
work with new people in general is I try
to be myself and not overcompensate on
the first meet because it sets the wrong
everything they'll think I'm something
I'm not but maybe
but what more than likely happens when
you try to do that is they see right
through it people are really good at
seeing through BS people can tell when
you're lying it's better to just be
genuine and honest so I think that plays
a lot in my favor
that's how I've gotten every other job
like I worked at the bioinformatics lab
before this and it that's not an easy
position to get I didn't even know
anything about bioinformatics but I'm a
programmer and I love working with data
and I can do that sort of thing so when
I went and met with the guy in charge of
hiring he liked me so he hired me over
there for anybody else and I think maybe
the same thing happened here there was a
lot of questions there was a coding stew
there's some coding parts my intense
unwavering study of C++ most certainly
helped in this interview they gave me a
problem and I was able to whiteboard it
out from beginning to end without any
significant hiccups like I solved the
entire thing and it wasn't something
that hard but it also wasn't something
that easy
in fact I honestly don't think I would
be able to do it just from my schooling
alone it was me working on other
projects that enabled me to get the
skills to do this white forward question
well because I spent so much time on my
own projects and just digging into C++
for solutions for all different a lot of
different things that some of them were
still relevant
you know that all sticks with you when
you really use it and you just do it
once for class doesn't stick with you
that well but since I basically did a
lot of the things that already that they
were asking for I was like okay yeah
I've done this I know how to do this
what I thought my head when they asked
me the question I kind of walked through
out loud what I was thinking how I
should solve it so they said okay we're
gonna ask you a question we basically
want to see how you do how your mind
works so I thought about their question
I answered out loud how I plan to solve
it and then I did it in code and they
asked me a few other questions like well
what if this or one of that and I
provided some ways to change the code to
make that work and they seemed overall
okay now this didn't go perfect I messed
up a little bit I couldn't remember some
of the syntax like I was like oh this
function from this library I can't
remember exactly how it's spelled like
getline it's like I could just use
getline here but I couldn't for the life
of me remember the parameters of getline
and I think I might have messed them up
on the whiteboard but I just kind of
went with it I was like I'm pretty sure
that's right but I also I was thinking I
kind of thought out loud because they
said they wanted to know my thought
process so I was like okay you can just
use getline here or you could do a CN
you know I could just kind of like spit
ball a couple ideas and I think and I
was like well I prefer to use this like
so
and I always I always mentioned if I
wasn't sure about something
thank you one of the things that they
kind of teach you in school especially
when you're taking tests and quizzes you
just give your best answer and that
doesn't work so well in interviews I
mean you do want you do want to give
your best answer but you also want to
preface it with that's something I would
need to research more before giving a
good answer and then say but if I had to
guess I'm pretty sure it's something
like this
so a few of the questions went like that
like I didn't know the answer so I said
something along those lines and also
give some example a lot of sample
experience for when I'm done done things
when they asked like also a lot of
interest in the company helps you should
be very interested in the company you're
going to work for if you're not you're
probably not doing the right thing maybe
you just need money and maybe you just
want any job I understand that too
[Music]
but you got to be interested I'm a big
advocate of being interested in what
you're doing it's your life go do what
interests you and yes you got to find a
way to make that thing make money which
isn't always easy I get that too because
I'm an artist at heart I I've been doing
creative things for my entire life
pretty much and never once have been
paid for any of them so I get that
that's a thing too so you got to make
that work somehow and I think the best
way is to just get really good at your
skill as good as you can and learn how
to market yourself learn how to talk to
people join whatever groups you need to
for support stay positive
don't don't don't put yourself down you
will make mistakes don't put yourself
down for it understand that mistakes are
just learning it's okay it's better that
it happens now then later because later
you'll know if it happens now so if it
happens now you're good
the habits later well it could cost you
something so go out and make mistakes as
many as you can as quick as you can in a
way you know not to any bro extreme but
you gotta you gotta get that stuff out
of the way I like to say when I'm gaming
with my friends sometimes when we have a
bad night or a bad run we'll say
something like okay we tried we got
stomped but hey at least we got that out
of the way we can start fresh again here
with new knowledge about things we
didn't know before and so that makes us
stronger and you know we end up winning
a lot of stuff as a group of teammates
just because of that not because we're
more skilled but because we're really
willing to to be honest with ourselves
you know that's a thing all right
well other things for getting a job and
don't be don't be afraid to reach out to
recruiters they're there to help you
don't be afraid to just reach out to any
companies you're truly interested in
just be heartfelt and your your little
forward to the the company your cover
letter if they're generic people that
companies don't really like generic well
some do like a you know if it's a not a
very personal company they won't care
it's like well you do the work that's
all they care about but those can be
real soul-crushing in my experience so I
wouldn't recommend a job like that
anyway you should do something you're
passionate about and that will really
help you a lot so get out there keep
programming
keep updating your stuff keep getting
working on things try to work on things
that matter make a difference help
people that way you'll get some some
stars on your your repos and you'll get
a lot of good feedback
and it'll be easier to maintain good
relationships which will bring you a
brighter future and hopefully a brighter
paycheck too to all you I wish all you
well if you're watching my channel thank
you thank you so much I didn't know what
to expect when I started this I wanted
to do a lot of tutorials tutorials are
incredibly tedious they really are and
they're hard to get right because if you
mess up one thing it's a lot of editing
so I'm gonna mix it up alright until
next time peace out guys love you